LEGISLATURES AND GOVERNORS, NOT
THE COURTS TO HAVE A
CONSTITUTIONAL RESPONSIBILITY TO
DRAW CONGRESSIONAL MAPS.
LAST WEEK'S INDICTMENTS AGAINST
MORE THAN A DOZEN RUSSIAN
INDIVIDUALS AND ORGANIZATIONS
ARE INCREASING CONCERNS ABOUT
THE SAFETY AND INTEGRITY OF THIS
FALL'S MIDTERM ELECTIONS.
TONIGHT CORRESPONDENT
PETER DOOCY LOOKS AT SOME OF THE
BIGGEST VULNERABILITIES AND WHAT
IS BEING DONE ABOUT THEM.
>> TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO STOP
MOSCOW FOR MEDDLING IN THE
MIDTERMS, DOZENS OF SECRETARIES
OF STATE SPENT THE LONG WEEKEND
IN WASHINGTON FOR MEETINGS THAT
STARTED WITH A PEEK AT PUTIN'S
PLAYBOOK.
>> AND MILLION DOLLAR A MONTH
OPERATION.
THAT GIVES ME AN IDEA OF THE
RESOURCES THAT WE ARE WORKING
AGAINST.
>> MOST OF THAT MONEY WENT
TOWARDS PROPAGANDA.
>> THE BIGGEST THREAT SEEMS TO
BE FROM THE AMERICAN PUBLIC
BELIEVING THE MANY FALSE STORIES
THAT WERE TOLD OUT THERE DURING
THE LAST ELECTION.
>> VOTING SYSTEMS ARE VULNERABLE
TOO.
21 STATES TARGETED BY RUSSIAN
HACKERS IN 2016 AND MANY
NETWORKS ARE STILL FLAWED.
>> FOR SECURITY AND MOST OF
THOSE ELECTORAL SYSTEMS IS
OUTDATED AND IT CAN'T MATCH UP
TO THE MODERN-DAY WEAPONRY BEING
GRADED BY THE RUSSIANS CYBER
ADVERSARIES.
>> DURING THE 2016 CYCLE, THE
FBI FELT THE SYSTEM WAS SAFE
BECAUSE IT'S SO SPREAD OUT.
SPEAK AT THE BEAUTY OF THE
AMERICAN VOTING SYSTEM IS THAT
IT'S DISPERSED AMONG THE 50 STAE
IT'S DISPERSED AMONG THE 50 STAS
IT'S DISPERSED AMONG THE 50 STAA
IT'S DISPERSED AMONG THE 50 STAD
IT'S CLUNKY.
IT'S NOT EXACTLY A SWIFT PART OF
THE INTERNET OF THINGS.
>> THINGS HAVE CHANGED NOW THAT
MORE PRECINCTS HAVE WI-FI.
>> AS THE STATES HAVE EVOLVED
WITH THEIR USE OF TECHNOLOGY TO
FACILITATE VOTING AND IMPROVE
THE PROCESS OF VOTING, THEY HAVE
EXPANDED THE ATTACK SURFACE THAT
CAN BE PENETRATED BY FOREIGN
ADVERSARIES.
>> BRIEFINGS WERE HELD FOR
OFFICIALS FROM EVERY STATE.
THE OFFICE OF THE DIRECTOR OF
NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE SAYS
SESSIONS WERE ABOUT "INCREASING
AWARENESS OF FOREIGN ADVERSARY
INTENT AND CAPABILITIES AGAINST
THE STATES ELECTION
INFRASTRUCTURE AS WELL AS THE
DISCUSSION OF THREAT MITIGATION
EFFORTS."
DHS OFFICIAL TELLS FOX NEWS THAT
32 STATES AND 31 LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE RECEIVING
REMOTELY OPERATED CYBER HYGIENE
SCANS FOR VULNERABILITY IN 14
STATES HAVE REQUESTED ON-SITE
RISK AND VULNERABILITY
ASSESSMENTS WHICH WON'T BE DONE
UNTIL MID-APRIL.
THE DHS SECRETARY KIRSTJEN
NIELSEN IS TELLING STATE
OFFICIALS IS ULTIMATELY UP TO
THEM TO KEEP ELECTION SECURE.
>> SHE HAS NO DESIRE OR NO
INTENTION TO TAKE OVER ELECTIONS
AND RUN ELECTIONS FROM THE
FEDERAL LEVEL TO THE STATE
LEVEL.
THAT'S THE THING WE WERE MOST
ENTHUSIASTIC ABOUT.
STICK WITH THE FIRST PRIMARIES
OF THE 2018 CYCLE ARE TWO WEEKS
FROM TOMORROW.
THERE'S A GREAT SENSE OF URGENCY
TO BEEF UP CYBER DEFENSES EVEN
THOUGH THERE STILL NO PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE EVIDENCE TO SHOW
RUSSIA OR ANYBODY EVER HACKED A